I could be my dog in this game so I'm
kind of a fan of that that's nice
my button yes oh we're all in yay
I like the gecko I'm gonna do gecko I'll
do a toasty everyone ready everyone
happy yeah yep so far I don't know why
Bongo yeah I mean it's adorable the
music and the comedy of us really good
yeah this is a cutscene we're supposed
to be watching of marriage yes sure
wasn't doubling a virus again I [ __ ]
love how the audio track on this is only
right track like it's a broken VHS oh my
god you're right we out here baby
Oh mine weird oh this is kind of cool
it's got like swaggy physics it's got
very like human fall flat swing a laying
physics okay everything all right I'm
down for this this is pretty cool I'm
weird my boys where we going
nope you're always full speed all I
wanted you're always consumed the toast
all right well whatever all right fine
yeah my game just got very blurry it's
fine it's fine don't worry about it
that's probably just internet stuff okay
so these are two person thing else all
right
Thanos love thing go see you can't thank
you
X or square there you go it does look a
bit like ass at the moment but the game
is cool oh don't worry
oh this I'll get it oh wait we have to
he've it okay dude wait you somehow blew
both of your toast loads Oh
this can't possibly now all right oh
wait you don't need to learn anything
get out of here all right get out of
here stop bread it's like his life bar
he runs out of bread eaters it dies oh
the ghost likes it when you slap them I
don't think the ghost likes it when you
slap them who you gonna call Oh mal
here's the mail it never fails it's
copyrighted
oh no they're gonna come after you for
that segment tomorrow you get a letter
from Blue's Clues here's the mail it
failed that would be the best season
just this letter
here's the mail it never fails it makes
you want to scream and wail please stop
using our song in your videos
I want a lawsuit all in rhyme god I wish
lawyers had senses of humor why am i
running wait only two seats up this is
gay racism the exercise where's your
truck we're the worth a big honking
truck are we all driving it together is
it just you oh no it's all its
collective we all have to collectively
decide we're here so we're moving some
stuff let us in all right Holly open
their door well I have a good night Lisa
hang on don't you're taking your stuff
taking your stuff now this feels like
totally reliable in the sense that we
have to get gold metals silver metals
bronze medals wait totally reliable had
medals yeah we didn't even deliver a
single game look they have an
nes/famicom thingy not for long they
don't so the things that have the
shimmer are the things with the grab
right if you hit Y it'll show you what
you need to grab okay if I don't get a
voice line that's fine sorry
why our triangle why are it cool gadget
things thank you some things things
the thing oh it's actually like do this
though right
no they just have to be in there it's
fine I mean helps if some of the big if
we do the big stuff first like like how
physics feet oh [ __ ] guys the window
wait wait Yakko over here come back
inside let's throw it out the window
let's bring it over the window let's
suck it out why is this game [ __ ]
reviews this is actually fun somebody
help me with this for a frigerator whoa
you gotta Bob you gotta bub you gotta
help me what are you talking about you
got it you got it I think we should
throw this bad boy up on top well I
think we should throw this bad boy well
that's not working I think we should
throw this bad boy on Marcus Martha
what's up
anybody know that's a big bed in here
queen-sized sorry I just ruined your
progress it's fine how about habit walk
the other way we mean how do we turn
things are pointed in the direction that
the trick I think it's more of a heat
than a heave whatever work out work a
sweat get it cool I broke a chair oh
well I'm a dog so I run real fast don't
break any windows I don't think so oh
how do you break windows and not break
windows in the same objective you're not
opposed to break windows one of them
did say break windows well you know to
do a multiple times or something I don't
know all right Jesus Christ is
definitely not the pepperoni palace that
Assad who changed Google Maps to say
their house was no pepperoni palace your
house people show up you're like welcome
to the pepperoni palace would you like
to buy this place I would be into that
called the pepperoni pepperoni palace
yeah you like pepperoni mom always told
me I had the best pepperoni so we
compared our under the other day
me and my boys you talk sometimes you
don't wanna talk about your pepperoni
know what came from the street that's
stupid
wait I think you got the best pepperoni
oh my god oh my god what is you're being
attacked by the turtle I've got it oh my
god I've got hidden
I've got wait wait let me help can we
throw him yeah where do we throw in
traffic from the road kill the turtle
won't oh it's a single it's a single
Percy's thrown by yourself oh god it's
Matt come on toast slap me
yeah why do i okay thank you my to get
rid of the burnt toast
all right it got something went to NES
graphics no one good
yeah yeah good man your internet just so
good oh my god who farted oh if I can't
I make toast I someone Spartan up a
storm what is that that's a that's a dog
there is no dog Bob I'm the dog seems
like a snob your way no we got this
going kid we're gonna have to he've this
[ __ ] even and I don't think you can
three-person heave I think it's a
two-person situation what the he you
guys got it I think you have to be
opposite each other okay
[Laughter]
well perfect well X again out of ten who
wants to help me move this bed yeah I
helped perfectly yeah you guys go
through the windows everything so hard
really window can we jump with this no
not really
we keep it awkwardly at the window and
try and wedge it out sure hey push and
jump yes
jump and push and shove wait no one's
worried about your burnt toast don't
worry
ten out of ten evening
wait no you guys can grab that table
fine yes you grab it to do person oh
okay wait
can you help wait wait the turtles
eating my ass right now turtle no
grunting get a mark I can't see go go go
go oh wow I don't think that tables
quite in there and it's fine oh boy we
need to choose a direction or a me
choice turtle yeah I think that mean he
likes you I'm not gonna leave this place
empty hands you suck okay that's rude
deliver the turtle we did no well those
aren't unlocked until you beat it once I
think it's the thing Oh what I did that
one that's you that's like come on we're
friends here maybe I don't know what oh
it's a unicorn yeah those things [ __ ]
ice cream I think just because this
rainbow colored doesn't mean it's
actually ice cream
no it's ice cream oh oh come on oh my
god calm down so just
mass does this truck oh you caught one
that's easy to do in three minutes give
us a challenge did you just do a line of
coke after you made that statement you
don't know watch my voice you guys wanna
make an only fans hell yes a drunk
minecraft themed only fans yes please
I've been hoping we'd get drunk and just
take some pictures and just see what
happens just crazy yeah yeah yeah no now
people help each other
perfect for our only fans waits over
here launching its toast in every
direction
no heave heave okay you saw the outline
you saw the outline was gonna do okay
now we got a turn now let me turn no no
turn by which mark means I got a turn
we're gonna where I keep them right out
yeah totally let's get these [ __ ] up
in here I'm chucking things to you to
make them easier Lily excessing that's
how much I love you guys thanks man
closer to the truck but not in it
apparently oops that one's going a long
ways god I can't see there's stuff in
here yeah it's like it's fun
everything's so obscene it can't be
shown over there in that corner of the
house yeah sometimes you just got censor
yourself you know this is but not on my
only fans where everything is uncensored
all the time somebody farted haha wait
wait wait who just threw my [ __ ]
cousin on the goddamn ground oh right
you're a toaster I get it right I gotta
chicken I don't know if we need the
chicken but you could still check it out
I cannot see bridge yeah that's a
two-person fridge buddy I think
everything else left over is two-person
well
you got one of those things all by
herself their money path is not good for
do people there's obstacles no we're
gonna have to let me get to another side
here it's like thread I'm gonna die oh
yeah that's only gonna eat your bread
out it's gonna eat your bread out we go
in this [ __ ] yep Oh God there we go
perfect I like chicken so you stole the
chicken let's take the path of most
resistance mark I'm your caboose baby I
see I love it when you say that yeah
all right wait I didn't shoot a load of
bread at me make sure you eat up think
twice before you throw my cousin on the
ground it was mark it was Bob is that
more believable yes why are we both
running there's an open seat haha
[ __ ] well we had a wait wait wait the
license plate Packer oh I was singing
punk ass [ __ ] that's that's a
different tone not quite what the game
is projecting but you never know who's
not driving this boat or what do we all
have to drive my thought it was more
just weren't moving okay
everyone was like well someone else will
do it Oh God does it just randomly pick
who's going in a direction at any time
no who was still moving oh yeah you know
what I think I can guess - it was me all
right fair enough that you would know
with certainty I did know that because I
did that the mark your tones they do
apply you thought was a certain my
Little Toaster not so little if you know
what I mean
yeah big toast I hope you don't get
anything wet ha ha yeah you should see
the spreads I got is it is this game
really gonna take came out on stage for
the Toros I do remember what we came out
on stage for the tour I never almost
like that was and it was terrifying
yeah that was a very fun wait I have to
catch those oh it's fragile right yeah I
can throw them in the truck though so
it's too I drowned men you guys need to
learn how to swim I know how to swim
because I'm a DA never mind oh we needed
to ban the hold the chairs all right you
know how this works right right okay no
I know it's a TV so like it's a TV it
can break we go we still win I can't
grab it
no here what am i what am i no you have
to all right wait stop moving wait stop
I'm not I am NOT me because weight is
literally standing still no it's way
it's fault Bob you know you can come
over here I'm doing stuff yeah yeah what
do you do well you nothing you're all
I'm doing stuff some throw some more
stuff you're gonna throw your mouth out
your ass
dude high five Thank You ru thank you
what's with this little car pileup
outside wait wait this is what I think
of you you think you would sacrifice
yourself dude I didn't know you guys
were such close friends that's crazy
what a selfless man that's what I mean
though that yah perfect man
Wiggy hot and everything if I might say
so myself I'm kind of crowded in this
movement wrong I think we're gonna we
have to throw it with no actually that
well what do you know what dude if it's
gold it's in all all right dude
slam that door nothing's gonna fall out
nailed it Gold we had to have gotten
gold I got silver [ __ ] I'll just eat my
way out what am i eating my way out of
what am i that it would be easier to to
navigate right but that my genius dog
self pointed out that you didn't you
can't walk across jello hey more slowly
Jack chameleon am i a chameleon or a
gecko pretty sure you're an iguana
wait you jump over that pool no no
no no Romani Jerry's apartment
I am an Argonian why did driving go so
well that time nevermind I don't want to
again I did goddamn thing that's what I
did alright now we're going to miss our
Steinfeld's place I love mr. Steinfeld
oh wait this straight up is actually
Seinfeld's apartment layout though isn't
it
I don't know is so there are no humans
in this world no just weird toaster
creatures and animals why weird I'm just
a toaster me normal toaster creatures
and animals every building you walk and
you blast your bridge out of money what
these are fragile dude the stairs all
the time
Oh Cal catch we should throw down to
someone yet okay the picture and someone
is to catch her okay that's the rules
got it nice first try
sorry mark I'm about to absolutely dunk
all over your face on my face are you
ready for this come in here oh I almost
threw it sideways there you go wait come
in here catch it I wish you could just
just just like a splat of blood on the
ground
mark I hope you're done with that bed
soon ah you made it nailed it nice but
if you're a sound of my voice I
protected it like a mother protect us
young by shouting at it like a mother
protects its young everybody knows this
don't don't go on joke on the ice
don't go yet okay what am I supposed to
keep quiet that I can't
well it's a fragile thing here my miss
and I fell out the window what a time to
be alive total jackass thank you thank
you I'm not ready I'm if you're gonna do
that you gotta at least try and get in
the truck
someone should probably
I'll go oh chameleons aren't known for
their speed perfect perfect
Oh Oh end-over-end toss Oh load the
truck yet I'm not there guys we load the
truck mark we're really fighting each
other on this one no we're good no no ha
ha who's in the truck now oh god they
don't have sick leave that said it's
fine it's fine
get back in the truck though oh we
almost got cold so this game this game
launched today just to be clear this is
a brand new game it's garbage reviews I
don't know why you should buy it this
game is the same company that made death
squared which is an awesome local
multiplayer platforming puzzle game this
is dope I'm really curious what the
reviews say cuz I'm having a great time
I mean it must be like 'wait experience
maybe they had a beta Ron of people and
the beta was rough and people just gave
it crap reviews on the over the beta
Channel or something Oh weird because I
didn't really play it very much in beta
and I didn't do the multiplayer I just
sort of looked at it because I was
excited about the game but uh it's good
now is that is the broadcast for you
guys consistent or is it fine it's
totally label it's really spotty usually
earlier than a couple times in the
middle but it's definitely not like as
bad as I remember it being yeah it's
usually when a lot of movement like
right now whoa what in the world did we
do I drown is there a way to increase
like your bitrate or something or I can
look me after this one take a look for
settings oh my god there's so much
gravity whoa whoa what a reference my
reference oh it's far as ball bursts
Ferris bulb ursday on fares barber
there's a bed down there fruit dude
nice thank you thank you he's on fire
someone better put it out you know wait
Bob appreciates my reference too early 9
section I don't know you don't and I
know Wow
I mean that as a compliment no no you
know no you guys no way that you mean
that as a compliment you can't do
therefore I must no no it is no matter
how many world leaders tell you that's
how truth works it's not yeah come on
that doesn't work either come on yeah
come on your way come on
Oh put this stupid table in the stupid
way I know who you're gonna blame but it
was probably me hello hello how does it
feel being alive once more I'm just
another clone of a clone of a clone
cascading forever always degrading I
can't see again oh I'm stuck inside look
at that big-ass couch what in the top
right look how big that yeah oh my god
oh it's squishy
blinkie's is a wiggle worm couch oh my
god I gotta pick a direction we gotta
agree I'm following you I'm just
following you all right for that I think
for that come help me with your voice
there look at my enormous chameleon
penis makes you feel powerful whoopsie
you go through the doorway it is
[Applause]
symmetrical navigation never solved
anything come on now yeah you're right
when you're ready that's helpful there
we go I'm starting to realize the
strategy might be maybe there's a
two-person crew and then one person goes
all the single stuff so maybe just
saying maybe next time like someone
should be the one person but star we
going through confused help me idiots
help help help pop hop hop hop shucks
and if that one thing hadn't taken us an
entire minute we could have totally had
silver people are giving me streaming
advice in chat they're like I got your
bit rates too low you gotta set it
higher mark I don't know if you know
about Street
let me hack into my bitrate real quick
the mainframe it's fine actually that
look better already looks better maybe
that'll make it a little more consistent
it was literally on max quality max
resolution oh yeah no it's it's way
better I'm good bronze yellow gooeyness
goosh out everywhere yeah now that's
offline oh no I hate that all I see is
just a mushroom stay dead forever I was
driving in the correct direction if this
is who's doing this it's finally proved
I can I'm holding my controller up for
the camera to see I was not mean you
can't blame that on me Bob sabotaging
himself hold up my controller - I'm not
summer chalant let's do this from now on
I'll always hold my controller up and
just to prove that I'm not the one
roller my hands backwards facing the
camera at all times yep yep all right
wait we should agree who's the
two-person crew and who's the one person
guys deserve each other all right wait
we got this all the two peoples because
now the bit rates better we're gonna be
able to see what we're doing yeah you'll
be at an equal disadvantage when I want
to like switch you and ruin your ruin
your videos oh you wouldn't dare yeah
cheating switching right now so hard all
right you see in what we're seeing you
see any scanning the scoping will start
me lighting we got to start proximal
because it'll get in the way of our
distal objectives will use the bedroom
window as our band will throw everything
it will heave it number I collect
everything down there up and all the way
around to get in there right oh yeah
yeah we do we do all right I know what I
have to do first
[Music]
it's a shallot it's a shoe only saw well
[ __ ] me God dang it go down the hill
utils oh not me go down the hill wait a
minute wait why wait you garbage human
coming up the hill wait why have you
done our plan it's got be hops what we
were supposed to heave it cuz then we
wouldn't have to walk all the way back
up why did we do this what to do what to
do what to do baby we'll get it later
we're gonna later okay one two there's
not many cuz I'm a table and washer here
I think okay or the couch we there were
two things that were too and we both
went to different things
coffee tables are a real big pain in the
sorry I cut you off there because I you
were still wait we gotta be over here
Baba I hate to say it but I don't think
our ability to do this is good I'm
sliding look what is with this traffic
jam here buff I've just [ __ ] stuff
down hanging I'm trying there's a lot of
one-person stuff in this house the two
things in here Wade our job ain't done
shmell Yamaha there was a bunch of
one-person stuff you guys were like
right next to you could have done
anything about but you were like oh we
and limited mission we agreed we agreed
we all agree cult leader yeah I have no
it's in my book it's in your book how to
follow me and why should that's a good
book why you should that's not the name
why you should Bob to be me me is always
Bob just to be clear he's perfect
that's good that's good that's good
that's good that's good that's good oh
we missed out on y'all it's good our
incredible strategy we're almost gold
yeah holy pretty good all right with you
mark let's touch this all right wait
here we go and nope
all right okay there we go
I'm just gonna dance with myself
you [ __ ] just get out of here that's
really sad
this a milfy yeah
MF l FY p no hey Mark it's not just what
you wanted what what what snowboarding
all I did was throw the snowboarding
down the thing I don't know I don't know
this game makes no sense
Oh unplayable I see why it has such
mediocre reviews now on playable in play
I'm holding my controller up oh I was
just gonna just run into it Bob we knew
I was I did that on purpose I was trying
to hit the snow man murder him you can
just go off the cliff oh yeah
do you see what we're doing to these
other humans in their automobiles kill
here's Billy we don't care about
children killing murder is a murder
you're not smarter in this murder all
right is it me and Wade again the two
team that sheep eating what is it eating
it seems to be stuck in the loop we need
to avoid the goop that's the lesson to
avoid to go understood the bad okay pull
it out pull out pull pull the bed out
Porter try the Manning way to pull out
Wow pull pull
[Laughter]
maybe hole with me
wiser words have never been spoken
[Laughter]
[Music]
there we go here we go here we go and
three two one boink I just really got to
work wait you want to see what I think
of your kind it's going with this
delicately right here Wow thank you well
I treat your kind with respect
I appreciate I'm gonna smack the [ __ ]
out of it Mike hi isn't your kind
toasters aren't you Rosie toaster man oh
my god I'm the one to be doing it you
clearly do it wrong oh my god oh god not
moving
I am the not moving one you you are the
moving to fix things okay here we go
ready yeah okay okay rule is we give two
heaves it's always times we have to
heave back and forth and then heave
there we go all right with to heave
we're two we're a to heaving team we
heaved back and then forth to eaves
perfect teamwork seems to be a lot of a
two-person long way through door
apparently
oh here we go here we go hey why okay
I'm not moving heave-ho heave-ho
oh that we are playing together we need
to like there needs to be a yoked you
know what I mean a yo eat because you
throw on the heat but we need something
prior to the heat we in a past particle
of eee-yaw eat that's it you're right
yeah yeah you're right
okay yeah I got hit by the car but you
only cared about the fridge getting hit
I didn't notice you died till you're
dead I went oh don't want to yah eat I
will stop you okay stop stop you you get
out of here wait let go for God's sakes
for one quick wait let go I think three
of us holding the same end of it it
might be issue alright okay okay wasn't
to say that we shouldn't hold any ends
on it okay
[Laughter]
like flash get out there are we not yeah
uh okay yeah okay you guys got okay
never mind I guess we get waiting gave
up when he was in perfect position mock
me mocking my panic
yeah that is the it's not the ha laugh
at him cuz it's funny it's the help of
helping you help him you look dumb be
just be you well you look like how do we
get bronze and kidding me we were so
close to gold trophies we did it Bob I
don't think Wade and I are the
two-person team I want to take mark
under my wing and teach him how it be
okay
I don't want you to trickle on me I know
don't drip on no you can't stop you I
don't want to go to snots work bonus
Knott's Berry but you're not gonna
trickle on me I'm gonna trickle on you
so good article on me I'm gonna do it
don't get out of here you upside out
piece of [ __ ] now it's here is that poop
no well maybe
move faster dieter named in this case
snots berry farm
hmm all right what are we looking at
Bose Y is a bales in the truck think of
it like moving a fuzzy microwave what
all right Bob
all right teach me you and me baby reach
me well there's not a lot of two-person
stuff grab the haunches
all right haunches what parts the hunch
you got okay there's a right there grab
it by its neck and strangle it hey let's
heave this bad boy all right I'm not in
position to heave it
we got a yayi not did you see how I air
bounced him that's very impressive
okay speed runner stuff right there I've
got it I got the hunch I got the minimun
we aha we got a yaw before we eat oh my
60s and then did not you hidden Oh
golden cow oh god mom oh he's trying to
escape
oh we got to put the hay bale and oh
he's leaving
well not for long here mark you you keep
the cow there's not a lot of two-person
stuff okay okay okay I'm just trying to
make sure the rails my [ __ ] chicken
if you I'm trying to fix throw it over
the hay bales I'm trying it's real
pixelated Bob fix your internet my
Internet's fine it's your internet fix
your internet everyone help stop
watching Netflix [ __ ] chickens these
chickens are rapscallions if ever there
was once the chicken
I got I got I got boy okay chickens in
I'm problem I'm becoming the master of
sheeps over here keep yourself dude
they're in the same place just not move
it's literally always no see out I get
hit by Rick okay alright hit by Rick I
almost said to you my own [ __ ] world God
okay words Oh God they're almost
breaking out what am I stuck on I'm
stuck in the doodoos brake semi
straight-up stuck in the doodoos over
here he's like what is this a trough
trough is it a trough I think it's a
trough yeah it's a trough I think it's a
trough is it pronounced trove trough oh
I hit the rake because I thought it was
mark for a second
oh you can't move because of the Dookie
straight up stuck in the dukey's I don't
know you've been saying it's been Dookie
from the beginning such a good catch
buddy I'm not in there oh you don't want
to be it kind of smells as Dookie in
here well how are you so good at moving
chickens
pork pork bark or crusty in their ears
that's I said we're chicken [ __ ] no
not necessarily but the question does
prop up if we're animal humans why are
there still am i much toaster
yeah we're decent mark what do you mean
you're right you right
alright poster you are a toaster yes got
it toaster gotta eat mark run it off
after what you said what how do you fix
anything that I said also but you're
running it off now as you're putting all
the chickens is bounces I didn't say
anything rude you're just afraid to
accept the truth
true true truth that's the truth he's
afraid of that you're afraid of that I
am that's it
all right good I am oh I'm so hungry why
am i hungry see chicken person what's
the deal with the chickens that you
moved there why are you yelling calm
down mark
something that everybody should be up in
arms about mark what's wrong with you
this is something that everybody should
be up in arms about I'm saying it's not
it's not weird mark
you're weird it is weird someone was
fighting me I'm not touching it at all
someone is all the way fighting me
currently no not touching it no I'm
trying to go this way okay there we go
and it wasn't touching a thing odd that
Wade wasn't denying and my controller
has been on camera this whole time yeah
haha
my controller was on camera the whole
time do the way you said that and the
way he said that after me made me doubt
it because I said I wasn't touching
anything as I was holding up the camera
I was letting my controller spot my
audience uh-huh good sorry I wasn't
really listening to this time see you
two again wait I think for fairness I
have to be you and me so we can show
mark done since he's so incompetent you
know understand competence
you don't understand competence mark
used to be good at this you're fragra
that's racist I am NOT okay wrong unfair
let's do this this frog really wants me
run run run run run run run run run run
run run to the right to the right to the
right don't stop to the right who is or
is not competent suddenly
middle middle middle middle you guys
wish you're half as good wait the key to
Frogger is never stop never slow down
for any reason because you will then
lose clear path clear path middle middle
middle chart shark shark shark shark
George and st. now that's how you do it
blur path clear path clear path yeah if
you yell it loud enough it becomes true
yeah well I guess we're trusting the
clear path we'll use are fine they're my
people clear paths never stop I could
you are pathetic wedge
you're pathetic that's what you are Wade
pathetic Wow see top ten one who's the
incompetent one wait if you stop
blasting your toast everywhere you know
never stop clear path why are you going
that way okay perfect okay I throw up in
my mouth full okay lemon sided with your
hands quick cut to a quick quick cook
cook phew I'm talking about Jesus and
I'm for the details does that mean I got
an achievement life I'd also spend it
moving furniture that's that's
depressing
[Music]